[Música]
[Aplausos]
hola a todos soy fernanda y me gustaría
preguntarles cuántos de ustedes consumen
contenido en redes por favor levanten la
mano
ok creo que todos estamos aquí dejé la
mano levantada a todos aquellos que han
considerado en algún momento en su vida
hacer algún contenido tipo podcast canal
en youtube blog
ok veo bastantes manos dejen la mano
arriba solo aquellos que lo han hecho
realmente
y aquellos que lo hacen constantemente
ok somos una minoría y éste les quiero y
es muy común las personas decimos este
yo podría hacer ese vídeo yo podría
escribir para un blog yo podría tener un
programa en spotify y nos encanta decir
lo fácil que es sin embargo pocos de
nosotros estamos lo suficientemente
locos para hacerlo muchísimo menos para
hacerlo semana con semana y mucha gente
pregunta pero por qué por qué no nos
animamos porque no lo hacemos cuál es el
reto y les arme un lindo vídeo para
explicarles qué es y cómo se siente y
por qué dejamos de hacerlo
[Música]
creo que después de ver esto y si les
digo precisamente que hacer contenidos
en línea es como sentarse de una de una
montaña y pocos de ustedes lo harían
estamos de acuerdo en gloucester
inglaterra desde hace 200 años se reúne
una vez al año un grupo de locos que
suben una colina con una inclinación de
30 grados que es créanme bastante es
empinada deciden arrojar un queso de 3.5
kilogramos que alcanza velocidades de
110 kilómetros por hora o sea 26 volts
con cocaína perseguirlo colina abajo y
intentar sobrevivir básicamente y esto
lo hacen ellos año con año si yo les
digo que hago yo esta semana con semana
dirían estás loca o sea está desquiciada
cómo te atreves sin embargo eso lo que
sucede cuando tú haces contenidos en
redes y quiero explicarles por qué el
festival de gloucester es exactamente
alentarte a tener tu canal en youtube o
tu podcast en algún medio
qué tienen en común estos puntos estos
dos eventos primero requieren muchísima
planeación tener un contenido en línea
no es como sentarse un sábado en la
mañana y echarse sin querer todo club de
cuervos en una jalada no no no no
funciona igual no sucede accidentalmente
tampoco puede ser ese plan que haces con
la amiga de irse a tomar un café
eventualmente y no sucede hacer un
contenido en línea requiere muchísima
planeación requiere que elijas ahora
vamos a ver aquí los puntos requiere que
elijas la colina perfecta o sea antes de
lograr convocar a gente a llevarla
tienes que elegir una plataforma que sea
adecuada para ti si eres una persona que
se siente cómoda frente a un micrófono
puede que sea un podcast y amas la
cámara youtuber lo tuyo
obviamente no todas las colinas han para
todos si arrojan un queso en una
planicie no es tan emocionante si nadie
se rompe huesos realmente vale la pena y
lo haces de los alpes suizos suicidio no
tienes una segunda edición entonces
tienen que hacer la inclinación perfecta
para que te rompas pero no mucho
y luego además de que haces eso
imagínate que luego tienes que caminar
20 minutos a través del lodo tierra
zhang o trepar la colina y aventar te
requiere muchísimo trabajo y requieres
hacerlo de las manos de otras personas
no saben cuántos proyectos yo he tenido
con amigos que dicen no es una idea
fabulosa y me dejan plantada el día de
la grabación esto sucede a cada rato
siguiente tienes que encontrar el queso
perfecto el queso es realmente una forma
de decir que tienes que encontrar el
contenido que funciona para ti o sea
tienes que encontrar el tema del que vas
a hablar que te hace único y especial
seguramente muchos de ustedes no habían
escuchado hablar de este festival el
festival del queso rodante entonces cuál
es tu queso rodante de que va tu tema
cuáles son las cosas que deseas o buscas
abordar en esta colina a veces podrás
intentar cosas que fracasan si bien
estás una docena de huevos se van a
romper no va a ser tan emocionante los
participantes se tienen que romper no no
el premio después de eso lo que tienes
que hacer es que tienes que ser
entretenido los hacía rojas un queso por
la colina y nadie está ahí para
atestiguarlo realmente hace sonido
para entretener además luego tendrás que
hacerlo probablemente de la mano de
varios locos que tienen un mismo
objetivo que tú son personas que
entretienen son colegas con los que
puedes colaborar o con los que puedes
armar un proyecto
y no sólo eso estas personas para ellos
es todo porque para que vale la pena
tanto show y tantos huesos rotos y no va
a estar alguien ahí para verte y sacar
la cámara y usar el hashtag indicado no
entonces tienes que tener a personas
dispuestos a hacer este trayecto y
acompañarte porque eso sucede en redes
cada vez somos más competidores cada vez
somos más los que estamos generando
contenido entonces tienes que tener una
audiencia que esté dispuesta a hacer ese
trayecto a caminar ese recorrido para
verte dar clic en tu canal suscribirse
poner las notificaciones
también tienes que tener padrinos y
aliados porque es una vida muy difícil
por un lado estos muchachos ustedes que
ven aquí son el equipo de rugby local en
mi vídeo no lo ven pero cuando estos
locos están aventando por la colina hay
unas personas que están listos para
cachar los y son ellos esta es una forma
de decir tienes que tener un nuevo es
una comunidad o alguien que te apoye no
digo los que te dan el view y el haití
ya sino que son los fans entrañables
puede ser tu esposo puede ser un fan que
recogiste en el camino y te apoya día a
día pueden ser tus mejores amigos pero
cuando te rompen los huesos alguien te
tiene que recorrer los 20 así los 20
minutos de regreso al hospital y van a
ser estos sujetos las primeras veces que
hagas el festival probablemente tú
pagues quizás el patrocinador de todo lo
que está sucediendo pero si esto lo
estás haciendo semana con semana vas a
terminar quebrado necesitas a daiana
smart en tu vida daiana lleva desde el
88 patrocinando un queso para que una
bola de locos sea de la madre
necesitas a today and a smart y necesita
de una bella no es marquesa temeraria
porque las autoridades probablemente
intentan desincentivar tu contenido
intentan limitarlo
alguien quería hello yo los apoyo
muchachos
y sobre todo impulsos suicidas cada vez
este evento y si ven los los años y las
ediciones anteriores se darán cuenta que
la gente bajaba con cuidadito la colina
y cada año es más salvaje es más haber
abrazado están vueltos locos y tienes
que hacerlo bien cuántas personas que
con los que ya finalmente hicimos el
trabajo la preproducción la grabación
las ideas en el momento en el que
estamos en la colina que es la forma en
la que tú abiertas tu contenido se raja
dicen esto no es para mí tengo mejores
cosas que hacer y no veo cubre mi seguro
médico entonces tienes que tener a
personas o tú tienes que tener la
disposición de aventar te hacer algo de
lo cual probablemente muy seguramente
vas a acabar lastimado
y lo más importante de todo es que
realmente el festival del queso o el
crear contenidos no se trata de ganar de
tener el queso si ustedes van a ingresar
a ser contenidos porque quieren ser el
siguiente influencers o quieren ser la
siguiente persona que adorna una revista
probablemente van a fracasar en el
intento y se van a sentir muy muy
frustrados para que vean esto chris
anderson que si ha sido un campeón este
por 14 años ha ganado 20 en 14 años ha
ganado 21 quesos y se ha roto muchos
muchos huesos y se ha lastimado órganos
ni siquiera le gusta el queso muchos de
los que ganan no les gusta el queso sin
nada más nos pensaremos en ellos nadie
estaría haciendo contenidos entonces
ustedes tienen que hacerlo porque les
gusta y sobre todo no se acerquen a
preguntarle su consejo aquellos que
están teniendo éxito porque saben que
dice chris que cuál es su secreto para
ganar
que nada más te tienes que aventar y
seguir caminando y seguir corriendo a
buen consejo si ves todos los vídeos de
años previos de los últimos 5 o 6 años
que yo los vi procrastinar no para esta
conferencia será una dar cuenta que
cristian una estrategia para empezar
crisis local conoce la plataforma la
consume la vive día a día ha recorrido
este trayecto por más de 14 años 14 años
ganando pero más haciéndolo y cuando
está bajando por la colina cris te pega
siempre a una estrategia tiene una ruta
sabe por dónde bajar la colina para
llegar más rápido que los demás tiene
práctica y esa práctica sólo te la da
del tiempo y el esfuerzo gracias
[Aplausos]